oh i know what this is
you've been able to sustain world peace
because you have one night a year where
you all run around robbing and murdering
each other without consequence
that's right what it's like the purge
morty hey wisecrack jared here and today
we're talking about future america's
favorite pastime
purging at first glance the purge seems
like your typical horror film
a decent concept any and all crime will
be legal for 12 continuous hours
questionable acting and all the violent
carnage you could ask for
but perhaps the scariest thing about the
purge isn't the creepy masks and rapists
with bad teeth but the way it highlights
the dehumanizing policies of our current
social landscape with a closer look the
purge can be considered a commentary on
our socio-political existence
a thinly veiled allegory for america's
corrupt politics
rigged economic systems and culture of
violence welcome to this wisecrack
edition on the philosophy of the purge
like the movie the perch yes that movie
sucked oh my god hold on the purge isn't
entirely unlike
other ritualistic festivals like mardi
gras carnival
or even halloween sure the purge is more
murder and theft and less dancing and
feasting before lent but they're
essentially the same concept
designated times where people can
violate social norms the purge is
halloween for adults
it may seem like these events are a way
to undermine the power law and religion
have over people
but it's actually the opposite they
reaffirm these social structures
the nffa or the leaders that sanction
the ritual aren't actually
challenged by the purge on the contrary
the chaos of the night leaves people
longing for the return of the law the
next day
it's kind of like a purge hangover if a
ritual like carnival exists to make
people
accept the tenants of christianity the
purge exists to make people accept the
tenets of the ruling social ideology
this societal order can best be
described in one word
neo-liberalism to another successful
year of the festival
pitting poor people against each other
for thousands of years
the politics of disposability the basic
idea of neoliberalism is that the
government should hop off the market's
nuts and only craft policies that
promote the free flow of goods and
protect corporate interests
each movie reflects a different facet of
the neoliberal economy
the way characters deal with the purge
brings to focus the conditions of their
respective economic class
the original purge is about the impact
of the event on an upper middle class
suburban family the sandins have
bird problems a sketchy looking homeless
guy infiltrates their gated community
their neighbors can't keep up with the
joneses so they try to kill them out of
jealousy you make so much money off of
us and then you just stuff it in our
faces
their daughter is hooking up with an
older dude that tries to kill daddy
sandon and their son
is creepy as hell the purge anarchy
focuses on the economic problems of a
working class family
eva sanchez can barely make ends meet
can't afford medicine for her father and
desperately needs a raise
you're really gonna ask her tonight i
have to i can't afford his medicine much
longer
the inner city is full of purge traps
gangs roaming around in taco trucks
dirt bikers kidnapping people every
apartment shown involves either
attempted rape or domestic violence
government officials round people up in
18 wheelers and people are abducted for
some sort of remake of the running man
you know detroit on a tuesday
if you compare the settings of the first
two films they can be understood as a
metaphor for white flight
the retreat of upper-class white folks
from the cities to the sheltered
poverty-free suburbs this abandonment
exposes those
left in the inner city to
disproportionate amounts of crime
homelessness and poverty or in the case
of the films purging
we're downtown everyone comes downtown
to perch
for the sandins the idea that they even
have to deal with violence against the
poor
is unacceptable because things like this
are not supposed to happen in our
neighborhood
the purge election year is about the
consequences of the holiday on small
business owners
joe finds out that the premiums for his
purge insurance are going up for
no reason why are you raising my rates
now today do you know what today is
something common when there are no
government checks to stop insurance
companies from doing you like that
they just raised the premium on my purge
coverage by thousands
the day before the damn purge if i don't
pay it by tomorrow i have no purge
coverage for this store they can't do
that yeah well they just did it
taken as a whole these examples not only
illustrate the injustices of the purge
but of our economic system in general
okay kids
no i know bad things do happen tonight
but we can afford protection
so we'll be fine just like always people
who prosper under neoliberalism
benefit from the purge and those who get
[ __ ] by neoliberalism
also get [ __ ] by the purge the upper
middle class largely profits from murder
night
the sanden's gaudy home remodel is paid
for by home security systems
sold to people based on the fear
manifested by the purge
you know your husband sold a new
security system
to almost every home in this community
but the working class
not so much since eva sanchez's boss
won't give her a raise they can only
protect themselves with a couple flimsy
two by fours
now that joe can't afford purge
insurance i just have to protect this
place myself
he has to spend purge night guarding his
deli with little more than a shoddy
rolling steel door
and eventually loses his life because of
it put another way the purge exposes how
neoliberal economics breeds a politics
of disposability
something explained by thinkers henry
giroux and brad evans
in the original purge suburbanites view
entire groups of people as
superfluous disposable it's the reason
the bloody stranger is referred to as
swine and filth by his foil the polite
stranger mr miss is the man you're
sheltering is nothing but a dirty
homeless pig it's how james sandon
justifies incapacitating and torturing
his houseguest
he is merely a means to saving his
family it isn't until the bloody
stranger volunteers to give himself up
that james finally sees him as fully
human
and decides not to turn him over to the
freaks in the purge anarchy the
unchecked price of medication forces
papa sanchez to sell his life to the
rich so his family can be eased of
economic hardship
one hundred thousand dollars will be
transferred into your accounts
as a disposable object his life is more
valuable to his family than as an actual
person
it's how the wealthy purge baby they buy
poor and sick people and they take them
into their homes
and they kill them where they're safe or
perhaps rick and morty say it best
this girl is one of your poor people and
i guess you guys felt like it was okay
to subject you to inhuman conditions
because there was no chance of it ever
hurting you it's sort of the
socio-political equivalent of say
a suit of power armor around you but now
things are evened out so
arthritia geru and evans argue that
people become disposable under an
economic system that is characterized by
privatization
of things like health care the
deregulation of banks and the erosion of
government safety nets like social
security and welfare
for the past 20 years the nffa has taken
a legalized murder to decrease
the poor population which in turn keeps
the government spending down
less welfare less health care less
housing if the purge stands as a
one-night reference point for the
terrors of such policies then shutting
down medical and police services
makes sense because government policy
can't possibly be more lacks than that
all of this is justified under the
banner of economic growth they're
keeping the population down by getting
rid of people like
us to save money the elderly infirmed
poor
and so-called non-contributors are
sacrificed so the economy can grow
unhindered these are the real victims of
the purge the people that the nffa are
trying to eliminate so that they don't
have to take care of him anymore
this elimination of the population is
actually paralleled in the real
neoliberal economy
people unable to afford epipens people
stuck eating ramen and the dollar menu
for 20 years or people exposed to
contaminated drinking water
pollution from coal factory plants and
nuclear waste neoliberalism exposes
those same populations to slow death
instead of actively purging them it just
sort of lets them die
this justification for the purge isn't
based on some new fancy economic idea
it goes all the way back to 1798 in a
book titled essay on the principle of
population
by reverend thomas robert malthus aka
reverend run
malthus argued that because production
would be unable to keep up with demand
a growing population would create
massive food shortages
his solution employ laws that keep birth
rates low
and death rates high things like famine
disease and wars
unfortunately the citizens aren't
killing enough so we supplement it all
to keep things balanced this is echoed
in the purge election year by caleb
warrens head of the nffa
idealistic pigs they want the impossible
everyone to have some cannot have
not enough to go around but does this
logic hold up
for friedrich ingalls of the hip hop duo
commie much beard
malthus had it all wrong the issue isn't
increasing population
it's an economic system that doesn't
value workers malthus was putting
economics
above people essentially angles argued
that malthus's model was nothing more
than an excuse to be a dick to poor
people
with their over-the-top purge ceremonies
the nffa
clearly have more than economic concerns
on the mind they take being a dick to
poor people to
the next level
neoliberal policies are confusing in the
abstract there's a bunch of economic
theory and political jargon you're
supposed to know
but the genius of the purge is the way
that it uses murder night to viscerally
expose how this kind of economy
generates profit in a predatory manner
profit making is not the essence of
democracy
wake up people wake up the privileged
make money hand over fist on weapon
sales
insurance private bodyguards and home
security systems while the poor have to
fight to simply survive
conclusion the purge movies may present
an opportunity to peek into a not so
distant dystopia
except most of the main characters don't
enjoy purging much
the rick and morty episode about purging
provides an interesting counterpoint
rick's sick enjoyment of the brutal
violence says more about the audience
than the films
if there's a video online with someone
getting decapitated you don't click on
it no
why why would i do that you do that i
don't because it would bore me i see
like that for breakfast morty sitting in
front of any of the purge movies puts us
in rick's position
oh my god this is awesome morty this is
really cool
perhaps the reality is we're the murder
tourist perusing through each sequel
excitingly waiting for a titillating
peek at something shocking and new
after all does anybody actually remember
any of the characters of these movies
you don't even know your names do we all
go see the next purge movie because we
can't wait to see what happens next with
the new founding fathers
or perhaps the success of the purge
films reveals what most of us
already know people like watching
violent [ __ ] because
well sometimes it just feels good